no one cares no one cares about you or
your story and now we insert one word
that changes everything no one cares
about you or your personal story unless
and that's the word that story or your
experience can help them and how do you
connect your story to them and the one
way you know is the personal pronoun
that you use the most and most ordinary
speakers use I more than any other word
their opening is this I'm so excited to
be here no one cares that you're excited
I've been thinking about this
opportunity to be with Heaven all week
long since he invited me to be with you
no one cares so here's a great way to
open three words you're here because
you're here because you're a movement
maker you're here because you've got a
message in you that's burning to come
out and you want to share that and you
want to monetize that that's the
difference so look at your last email to
a client or a customer Circle how many
times you said I and how many times you
said you an email is a presentation a
video is a presentation a phone call is
a presentation a zoom training call like
this is a presentation it's got to start
somewhere it's got to end somewhere and
it's got to be about them it's not about
you
what you're about to watch is a sample
from my movement makers training it's
where I train thought leaders to build
their movement make an income have an
impact around the world I train in the
group twice a month and start to bring
in my friends as well to share their
expertise and wisdom if you want to join
us movement makers is the link in
description below and for now enjoy this
clip I am joined today by a special
friend this man is a legend Mr Joel
Weldon we're going to talk about
speaking how to turn it into a career
but before that I'm going to read his
quick bio so this one of the things that
Joel does I guess it's not a bio it's an
intro he has people read off of a black
cardboard with some with some words on
the front so this is Joel here you don't
have to use humor as a speaker unless of
course you want to get paid well there's
a lot more than being a professional
speaker than using humor and that's why
Joe Weldon is with us today Joel has
been a full-time professional speaker
for 48 years he's been inducted into the
professional speakers Hall of Fame he's
been paid speaking over 3 000 events
he's personally coached over 10 000
speakers and now we get to learn from
him today plus he's an original founder
of the National Speakers Association
please welcome Joe Welcome to our
discussion well movement makers great to
see you you know you're here because you
want to be an even better speaker and
monetize that thing so thank you Evan
for that great introduction
you know he mentioned about using humor
so many times people think that's
important it is important but there's a
lot more to that I mean like people ask
me you know you've done all these things
how old are you my answer is always the
same my social security number is five
so I've been around a long time
but seriously for you
getting paid to speak is a whole
different transition than using speaking
to grow your business and I think we
need to talk about that because the most
important thing is you want to think
about how can you monetize speaking two
ways by getting paid a fee to speak or
using the platform to generate income as
a coach as an author as an entrepreneur
and in many cases generating
substantially more money by doing that
than you could by a speaker's fee
so with that said think about you as
hiring a speaker if you had a business
or a company or an association and you
wanted a speaker
why would you bring in a speaker
to bring information to your audience to
your members that they don't have access
to
which means you need to know something
that people don't know and as an example
this guy next to me Evan we're part of
Genius Network when Joe polish brought
him in Evan knew more about using
YouTube videos and creating them with
almost a half a billion views three
million followers
I we don't know anybody that's done that
so that was very important and that's
why an introduction is important what
gives them the ability to speak on that
subject when Evan was introduced I wrote
that introduction for him here
it was amazing how receptive the
audience was that's why he had to
introduce me to you because you don't
know who I am and it doesn't even matter
who I am what's important is you what
are you going to do with your knowledge
and your wisdom that you want to share
with others
now one of the things Evan told me in
preparing for this that you have a very
dramatic personal story that as a
movement maker you want to spread what
you've learned or your experience and
you share your personal story
let me give you one piece of advice
about your personal story no one cares
no one cares about you or your story and
now we insert one word that changes
everything
no one cares about you or your personal
story unless and that's the word unless
that story or your experience can help
them
and how do you connect your story to
and the one way you know is the personal
pronoun that you use the most and most
ordinary speakers use I more than any
other word their opening is this I'm so
excited to be here no one cares that
you're excited I've been thinking about
this opportunity to be with Heaven all
week long since he invited me to be with
you no one cares
so here's a great way to open three
words you're here because
you're here because you're a movement
maker you're here because you've got a
message in you that's burning to come
out and you want to share that and you
want to monetize that
that's the difference so look at your
last email to a client or a customer
Circle how many times you said I and how
many times you said you
an email is a presentation a video is a
presentation a phone call is a
presentation a zoom training call like
this is a presentation it's got to start
somewhere it's got to end somewhere
and it's got to be about them it's not
about you
you already know the truth you've
experienced them
now with that said in our first six and
a half minutes together let's stop and
open it up to any questions comments or
thoughts you have how do you decide how
to do this I'll play along I see we've
got Nancy with her hand up already let's
see what she's got for Joe
excited to be here with you because my
goal is to get on stages live in front
of people I've done videos and podcasts
but I really want to be on a stage and
one of the things I'm curious is how
many different speeches did I have
should I have one or should I become
adjusting and adapting to the different
audiences in different stages
uh yes
uh yes to both yeah well the last thing
you said is the most important should I
be adjusting and adapting to different
audiences so Evan mentioned you know
I've been paid over three thousand times
to speak never did I give the same talk
okay now ninety percent of it eighty
percent of it seventy percent might have
been similar to other messages but
unless it's relevant to the people
you're talking to
it's not going to connect so there was
an adage in the beginning days of
professional speaking to have one talk
and change audiences
just give the same talk over and over
and hope it fits and in many cases
speakers were able to come up with good
material people loved it and they became
successful at it that was not the
approach that I used my Approach was
based on what I told you nobody cares
about you they only care about what do
you know that's going to help me
and if you think about these three words
what do you know that can help me meet a
need that I have
overcome a fear or concern or a worry
that I have or reinforce a victory or
success that I'm presently experiencing
and if you can do that meet a need
overcome a fear reinforce a victory
then if you knew that about your
audience you could adapt your material
to do that so Evan told me about you as
a group that many of you are coaches
you're entrepreneurs you're part of his
organization you've got a power within
you that you want to share with other
people and speaking is going to be one
way to do it
so yes you could have one talk that you
adapt or if you have expertise in more
than one area you could do that so I had
many different areas I specialized in
sales in leadership and in personal
development those are three very broad
topics but over 48 years of developing
materials so I figured I had 70 hours of
stage time without repeating anything
wow but it was customized and one other
thing to think of in my entire career I
never had a demo video
never worked with an agent or
salesperson never did any marketing
didn't even know what marketing was
until I joined genius Network eight
years ago and met people like Evan
all I did was an amazing presentation
they hired me again or referred me to
someone else and that's how I built a
career
some hired me 70 times 60 times 50 times
in big companies to use that material in
different parts of their organization
but the key was
it wasn't about me
it was about them and how maybe this
experience that I brought could be used
by them to meet a need overcome a fear
or reinforce a victory so does that
answer your questions yeah that's the
that's perfect I love that and I will
take that and include that in my work
going forward thank you okay let's move
over to Rose hi okay so how do you give
a speech that goes like straight to the
heart that connects with them
um inside here that makes up like makes
them like
feel something
I don't know if that makes sense or not
yes absolutely that's a very important
thing well how do you connect with
anybody on an emotional level
I think one of the ways you do that is
when an audience knows that the speaker
understands
their situation
and now you have been everybody on this
call has been in the audience and you've
been Rose you've been in the audience
many times have you ever heard a speaker
where you're thinking to yourself they
don't have a clue what I do
that that has nothing to do with me
like you're not going to connect on an
emotional level
so knowing just using our experience
here what Evan told me that you Rose you
have something inside of you a life
experience a trauma a tragedy a victory
something you did that has moved you
forward in your life and you feel that
this experience you've had or knowledge
that you gained can help other people
and you want to share that with others
is that true about you yes okay all
right now without knowing what that is
I don't care
you're not important to me now I don't
mean that literally now with you because
you're part of Evan's group I love you
but one of the things you need to think
of is how can you connect that
experience with what they're going
through
so let's just say the audience is part
of two organizations that have merged
together Acquisitions and mergers are
happening all the time and somebody in
one of those organizations knew about
you and they wanted you to come in to
help make this transition even better
you need to know what are the
differences in the two companies what
are the people in those seats thinking
about is my job going to be cut are they
going to take somebody from the other
company and I'm out is my pay going to
go down that's what's important to them
and so many times speakers talk about
what's important to them as a speaker
this is my favorite subject no one cares
here's a subject you're going to find so
helpful today
that should be the tone of your message
and if you think about that if you can
create a message that connects with the
people you're talking about or talking
to they're going to want to hear more
from you which means they want to hire
you again or they're going to refer you
to somebody else
those are the best ways to grow your
speaking business
so does that help Rose yes that does
help I have one more question how do you
engage your audience and what techniques
do you use to maintain uh their
attention
you talk about them
so let's confuse this hypothetical thing
about to a company a and Company B have
merged together and now it's called a b
a b company
you're here because you're either part
of company a or Company B
and whichever organization you're part
of you're now part of a and b
and as you're sitting here you might
have some concerns
what's going to happen to your job
is it going to be eliminated is somebody
from the other in other words your
preparation you're working ahead of time
to understand them if you're talking
about that and that's what they're going
through they're thinking Rose knows
what's going on here I can't wait to
hear what she's going to say of how do I
handle this
does that make sense yes thank you thank
you and that's why with Nancy's question
you don't have one talk
you've got to customize that message
like this guy about YouTube yes but
we're talking to entrepreneurs here so
he adjusted that first time he was here
to our needs
and it resonated and now he's here all
the time let's go thank you rob Tanya's
got a question we got Tanya my question
is what do you or how can one rescue
uh yourself when you know speech is
going really bad and you have a
non-responsive audience and things are
not the way you expected and every
thought starts stumbling in your head
and uh you feel that okay I'm losing
them
I'm sure that you probably had
experienced that at some point and how
you rescue or how do you manage those
situations thank you well
the answer is no it hasn't happened
and one reason is preparation
if you're prepared
if you understand your audience and
from a Time standpoint the majority of
time should be spent in preparing
not your material
but preparing how does this material
relate to them if that was the only
thing you did if you knew in advance by
working with the person who hired you or
brought you in what the what's the
audience going through what are their
pain points and then asking this
question just imagine when the meeting
is over everybody shakes your hand and
says this was wonderful and you say
great I'm glad you liked them
what are you going to do
can you tell me the three things you'd
like to hear your people say they're
going to do
if you did all that you won't get off
track now you might forget what you're
saying then you just here's a simple way
if you feel like you're missing the boat
things are not happening the way you
want that was your question right what
do you do tell the truth let me just
stop for a minute I've completely lost
my train of thought I don't even
remember what I what was I talking could
somebody help I was in the middle of a
story and I went on a side track what
should I do next you were talking about
the day you were falling off a glacier
oh yeah okay all right
just tell the truth be honest or
and I've here's an experience I had I I
felt I lost the audience I had talked
about the CEO I knew about him he wasn't
at the meeting
and I just felt this terrible disconnect
so I just stopped there were like 500
people in the room
and I said
could somebody help me I must have said
something
that I shouldn't have said
what was it and the room was dead silent
and then somebody raised their hand and
I said can you help me he said yes you
know you were mentioning our CEO
this is the end of our three-day
conference you weren't here in the
beginning but they opened the meeting
and said that Bob that was his name had
a heart attack
and they were going to give us an update
and we haven't heard anything and when
you were telling that story about Bob
which was part of my preparation I found
out about this guy had a great sense of
humor and I was telling a story about
Bob and that's when I lost the audience
I didn't know what had happened
but when this guy said that that the
reason we just stopped was because
we don't know what happened to Bob
we don't know if he's alive or dead he
had a heart attack first day of the
meeting
I said well thank you so much for doing
that let's do this let's all close our
eyes and in your own way
let's take 30 seconds and send our
thoughts to Bob
and I just stood there I counted to 30.
and then I said and you know one of the
things I started telling that story
about Bob is he had a great sense of
humor and he loved to be in front of her
let's give him a standing ovation
Bob this is for you everybody up let's
clap for Bob okay
and I went back to the story now people
say how did you think of something like
that
just tell the truth
I had no idea what I did but like you
said I felt this disconnect so that's a
suggestion it's not going to be
something like a heart attack and not
knowing but there could be something
that has nothing to do with you that had
nothing to do with me except I mentioned
his name and that triggered that
response and that's tuning in to your
audience and you can't do that if you're
not prepared if you don't know your
material how are you going to be
flexible and respond
so hopefully that's helpful for you
very much prepare prepare prepare and
then prepare a little more Karen in the
house
Karen's got for Joel hi I aspire to be a
speaker that's what I really want to do
at this time I belong to this amazing
organization Toastmasters International
and I feel like I'm the queen of the
five to seven minute speech at this
point but I have two questions one how
do I transition from giving speeches
within Toastmasters to stepping outside
of Toastmasters and becoming a paid
speaker
well by a show of hands raise your hand
if you have been or are now a
Toastmaster
okay we've seen we got some all right I
joined Toastmasters in 1969.
I'm still a member every Monday I'm at
my club
it's one of the best things that
happened and why I'm still in
Toastmasters is because that's how I
became a professional speaker
because I couldn't I couldn't lead my
Sunday school class in silent prayer I
mean that's bad I was so shy and
self-conscious until I joined
Toastmasters so you're in a great place
now if you're not a Toastmaster you
mentioned that it's a five to seven
minute speech how do you transition that
into professional speaking well if
you've been good in Toastmasters which
means you get constant feedback from
your fellow members of what's working
and what's not working
thank you so the way you get speeches is
start telling people you know in
addition what do you do what is your
main source of income now
well right now I'm a caregiver to my son
who has autism but I'm transitioning
from caring for him and being a fitness
instructor I'm putting it all into
speaking that's really what I wanted
what are you going to speak about
I'm going to speak about weight loss
I've lost over 100 pounds I'm going to
speak about my experience I want to
speak to the autism moms in particular
my son who has autism is now 18 years
old so that's 18 years worth of
experience and I think that'll really
come in handy to parents who are
recently given that diagnosis of their
child
all right so I would talk to everybody
you know and tell them you know that
I've kind of this experienced with
autism and with with weight loss and I
have a number of talks that I give and I
was wondering are you part of any
organization
that brings in speakers that you could
recommend me to
and the nice thing is I don't charge
anything at this point
so in the beginning you want to get out
there if you want to be a speaker speak
and the best way as you're listening to
this talk to the people you know say I
have a number of messages and we've
gotten great feedback are you part of
any organization that brings in speakers
that you'd be willing to recommend me to
that cost you nothing to do that the
other thing you need to do is get
feedback so Toastmasters taught me to
get feedback so every presentation I've
given there's a written feedback card
that critiques that presentation the
content the delivery what the best idea
was and what could have been improved
and I've had millions of those cards
turned in and read every one of them and
that's how you get better and better and
better and that's how you know what
material is working by looking at the
ideas that come up the most so with Evan
one of the things I asked people when he
first spoke what was the best idea that
the thumbnail should match on all your
videos when you put them on your library
that simple idea but people really
picked up on that if you knew that you
could make sure you always emphasize
that
the next time you talked and if things
don't show up you stop talking about
them
so we're almost out of time and I have
22 words to leave you with when the boss
says it's time to go well so hopefully
that helped you can I just ask one last
question I'm not a comedian I really see
the value in humor it helps your message
get across if you're not naturally a
funny person how do you add humor use
visuals that are funny
we could do another session on that
all right thank you the boss is nudging
me so uh we've got like 30 seconds left
before we move on with Joel final
thoughts wisdom close what do you want
to share with us 22 words sums are
everything that's taken almost 50 years
to learn about speaking I'll say them
slowly twice
speak to your audience about what they
need
in an organized way they can follow
and get yourself
out of the way
speak to your audience about what they
need
in an organized way they can follow
and get yourself
out of the way
and hopefully you'll make it a great day
Joe well then everybody people want to
find you follow you work with you where
are they going
well if they want to talk to me they can
just go in my calendar get a 15-minute
call talk to joel.com
and that's it talk to joe.com if you
want to join us in movement makers check
the link in the description below
otherwise enjoy this video right here I
think you'll love it